meet ayla
she's the daughter of evangelical
christians from idaho so poor they
couldn't always manage to put food on
the table a former factory worker who
never graduated college she became one
of the most successful performers on the
adult subscription site only fans
earning in some months over a hundred
thousand dollars on the platform she
still does one-on-one appointments but
only with clients who can afford to pay
top dollar
what's your price right now three
thousand dollars an hour
but ayla is also known for her oddball
social media polls sexy and silly
personal moments on twitter and for
using her giant platform to spread hot
libertarian takes such as declaring i
like capitalism i think generally most
of what the government does should be
privatized i don't think it should be
involved at all in healthcare social
security or welfare i am not okay with
you making laws that prevent me from
doing what i feel is good for me like
that is the border here this is what
like the respect of freedom is ayla is
also an outspoken defender of sex worker
rights who compares her current life to
what it was like at the age of 19 waking
up at 4 30 am to put in 54 hours a week
doing repetitive tasks on an assembly
line in a windowless factory why do
people talk about survival sex work but
not like survival factory work or
survival burger flipping she wonders yes
there's exploitation in sex work but
decriminalizing sex work would let
workers actually go get police health if
they needed it but even before she got
rich and famous back when she was
scraping change off the ground to eat
ayla says she still had libertarian
economic views i met up with ayla at her
home in austin texas for a wide-ranging
conversation about everything from how
sex work made her a better data
scientist to why many successful
practitioners in her industry are
selling not just sex but the personal
connections that so many of us are
missing in our lives
the entire session was just like me
holding him as he sobbed into me
and that was it we didn't have sex
i've had sex with a quadriplegic who was
like literally in in a chair who
couldn't move
i was like yeah that feels good like i'm
helping you get something that just you
can't get anymore it feels really human
and caring to me
so
do you recall the moment you first
decided hey i'm going to put my naked
body on the internet
[Music]
damn
i had worked at a factory for a year and
it was really terrible what type of
factory i was on an assembly floor
assembling electrical relays so they're
like using electrical systems to like go
off and protect us or manage i don't i
don't remember a long time ago but i was
standing on the floor and like my little
uniform on an assembly line doing the
repetitive motion over and over again
and we worked long hours like 50 hours a
week we had to be there at like 5 00 a.m
and left you know three or something
like that
and it was terrible
there were saturdays and it was just
absolutely mind killing so it was really
soul killing and then after that i was
like okay [ __ ] this i'm just never gonna
work for a boss again i'm gonna try and
do my own thing and i was really
incompetent so i failed at doing my own
thing but then i was uh like briefly
dating this guy and he said hey there's
this camming thing you can like stream
yourself live and you know if you want i
can help you do that
and i we ended up never doing it but
after we broke up i was sitting there
like sleeping on my friend's couch uh
being like what the [ __ ] do i do i guess
i'll just try this this thing
interesting and so you got into camming
and what was that like initially really
scary because i had come from an
extremely conservative culture like
really conservative what religious
background is your family christian
fundamentalists okay calvinist
evangelical calvinist wow that's an
interesting background yeah you know
yeah about the familiar with them yes
scared of them slightly yes
yeah your calvinist my dad is a
professional evangelical debater he goes
around debating people about the bible
and stuff so from calvinism to factory
to camping basically there were a couple
intermediary steps but roughly yeah
and what was that new life like when you
started camping was it something where
you immediately found it was a lot more
stimulating in terms of thinking of your
strategy and how to make money for
yourself and how to really uh provide
for yourself or was it the type of thing
where you actually realized that parts
of it were just as tedious as the
factory work had been eventually but for
a long time it was extremely good
camping was a way that i could actually
better myself in a lot of the previous
things jobs i've been working like in my
life i'd had a very like small
expectation of what my life could be
because i was brought up to be a
housewife who would maybe marry a middle
manager somewhere and have five kids
immediately and so when i was like okay
i'm not that's not the life for me i
didn't have like oh i could go to
college right and i could become a
lawyer like that was just not in the
cards uh and so when i started camping i
made 60 the first night and i was like
this is more money for four hours of
work than i've seen in my lifetime i was
extremely excited and it was something
where i could actually like see results
from working really hard and that was
the first time i've been put into a
system where i could work really hard
and have like concrete results from it
and so i just became obsessed with it i
lived it breathed it went to sleep
thinking about strategies i had a lot of
fun i put on really creative shows and
it was awesome for for several years and
eventually it got old you know because
it's repetitive so after it got a little
bit more tedious and wrote it seems like
you you move to escorting and escorting
requires in-person interaction what
appealed to you about this did this feel
like a really big step
it did kind of surprisingly there's sort
of a cultural uh like line inside of the
camera world you know their cam girls
like do escorting cam girls who just
don't do that and so in the cam girl
lounge there was like oh we're all cam
girls of course so we never actually
[ __ ] a man for money that's like a
little and then there are a couple
campbells who did it and you would like
gossip about it or something and so i
had sort of this idea that i wasn't i
wasn't that kind of person really um i
had absorbed a lot of uh cultural fears
about it people i had something in the
back of my head that was like oh if i
accept sex for money i'm gonna be like
dirty or gross or feel bad it's gonna be
psychically damaging or something do you
think those are calvinist cultural fears
or camming world cultural fears i think
because it seems like there are taboos
and stigmas coming from sort of both
areas in an interesting way it's not
even just those two it's the entire
world yeah it's everybody thinks that
escorts are
not sexually valuable like as a mate i
mean to [ __ ] yeah but like not as not
like impregnate what was escorting like
tell me a little bit about that
transition um did that require you
basically acquiring an entirely new
skill set or was it something where you
were able to build off of some of the
creativity and the personal brand that
you'd almost carved out for yourself via
camping oh they were totally related it
was really interesting to go into
escorting because i had a very long
history of working really hard as a
successful cam girl i felt like i came
into escorting expecting it to be hard
but found that a lot of the skills that
i had from camming just very naturally
went over to marketing like i already at
this point understood what men want in a
pretty intuitive level i knew the kind
of photos that worked really well i knew
the kind of like personality and
strategy that men really respond to what
types of things do they respond well to
your clients yeah so men want
personality
they really do and there's some sort of
this fantasy that you're selling the guy
on like i'm not just like a body for you
to [ __ ] i'm some sort of like escapism
that you can like fall in love with for
a night who's you know warm and bubbly
and fun to be around makes you feel
great about yourself and a little bit
therapy involved too is it like a
summoning a sort of manic pixie dream
girl type vibe or is it like a different
form of charm it's pretty manic pixie
at least a bit and obviously girls have
different strategies right there's a
couple of girls with strategies that
work who are very different from me but
yeah usually you want to be like the
dream girl who's like careless who like
desperately wants to suck your dick
who's like really excited about life
who's gonna bring you out of your
mundanity um and so i just like put that
into my marketing for escorting and it
went really well what did the economics
of camming look like and then the
economics of escorting what did your
business model look like with camming
most of the income comes from a small
percentage of men because the men are
visible to each other and so there's
much higher competition as a guy if
you're like tipping the girl or giving
her money it's in front of other men
which means that if you don't have
enough money you are discouraged from
tipping the woman because you're going
to like sort of lose the competition
it's very competition oriented and so
you end up with a system where like 80
of your money comes from like two guys
uh basically wow really oh yeah it's
extreme and this leads to a lot of
vulnerability for emotional abuse too if
all of your
money or like is coming from just a
handful of guys
then they can make a lot of demands on
you and you have to sort of respect that
because if they dip out it's like a
really big hit
whereas with escorting
not the case at all because the guys are
not visible to each other they're not
competing against each other in any way
your income is like much more
distributed across men could you talk a
little bit about the class differences
in types of sex worker types of
prostitution
yeah i did a survey of a bunch of
escorts basically in fact like the
amount of bad things they encountered
like a sexual assault or theft or you
know police or whatever it was look
pretty strongly correlated with uh their
price range like the amount of money
that they charge per hour so basically
the more money you charge you're sort of
like pricing yourself out of like more
sketchy clientele
the people who are going to be paying
you a thousand dollars an hour are not
going to sexually assault you uh they're
like a lawyer or a doctor or a
politician or something who just like
just don't want to [ __ ] with that it
seems like you made a somewhat
deliberate decision as you sort of went
from from the factory to camming and
then to escorting and then you became
highly selective with your clients i
imagine some of this is partially due to
you being in high demand but also some
of this seems like a deliberate choice
on your end to try to make this
situation um safe for you and to allow
yourself to have a lot of autonomy in
terms of who you choose it seems like
you sort of opted into high-end sex work
in a very deliberate manner is that
correct to some extent yeah i started
charging about 800 an hour and then i
eventually raised my prices to 1200. did
you notice a big difference between
clients like the clientele that you
that that sought you out at 800 versus
the higher end yeah it wasn't a massive
difference but there was definitely
noticeable there were definitely guys
that was like uh
all right this is job this is work let's
just think of our happy place and those
price sensitive are these clients yeah
the great ones tend to be less price
sensitive in general and when i raise my
prices the kind of guys that were really
a dredge to deal with typically faded
out not you know 100 but there were
definitely way fewer of them have you
ever experimented with pricing to such
an extent where you raise your prices so
high that so many people get priced out
that it ends up not becoming lucrative
like have you experimented with the
upper end of that uh this is what i'm
doing right now actually
because right now i've switched to
researching like i'm funded to do
research right now so i basically quit
sex work and so i was like [ __ ] it i'm
going to raise my prices like really
high because that's just for fun yeah
because i still really like escorting
like it's still a fun experience and
sometimes i noticing myself missing it
like it's a really easy great way to
have sex with a new person um for for
for some benefits on the side too so i
i'm doing that right now um and so i do
have some interest yeah may i ask what's
your price right now three thousand
dollars an hour have you noticed any
demand yes definitely reduced
it's still there so you moved away from
escorting and toward retirement how did
that transition happen because it seems
like you've really carved out a huge
space for yourself online both in your
writing and on twitter
as this sort of like rationalist public
intellectual data collector and so it's
i think it's very rare to have somebody
who is such an authority and who engages
in sex work but who is also this almost
like data scientist type um what has
this this sort of dual identity been
like for you and did that influence your
retirement basically yeah they really go
hand in hand i'm surprised more sex
workers aren't also data scientists like
i went from escorting to only fans
because covet hit and
it was like right before covet hit i got
a client sick with the flu accidentally
and i was like okay i don't want to risk
this
again this would be really bad i don't
want to kill anybody um so i stopped
that and went into only fans and only
fans you get a very large reach uh only
fans you have to just like get as many
followers as
as many platforms as you can and that
really blew up my ability to do surveys
with really high sample sizes
so
i just started doing that even i had
been doing it before but at this point i
was doing it even more wait so your
platform became large review only fans
like you were
getting
survey results you were having your only
fans followers be your respondents or
was it that your profile overall was
blowing up and so that only fans fame
translated to twitter it's something
like in order to do only fans very well
only fans has a 50 churn rate of
subscribers per month
which means that 80 of the work that i
did with only fans was generating new
eyes on this constantly like very high
visibility which meant that i was
capturing uh followers free followers on
a lot of platforms like i have 350 000
followers on reddit for example and like
almost 200 on fatlife 200 000. and so i
had a lot of platforms with lots of
subscribers on all of them
and that was what gave me the ability to
do the surveys were you worried
initially that people would think that
it was weird or a distraction from the
sexual content not necessarily because
uh one aspect of selling sex to men is
that you're selling them an identity
about themselves right that men like to
think of themselves as the kind of guy
who likes this kind of girl even if they
don't actually like it really even if
they don't independently pursue data
themselves so if you're like hey i'm a
sex worker and also i do data they're
like wow i'm such a high-end guy that i
like am attracted to this hot woman who
also does data look how like deep i am
right so i'm also this is also selling
the guys an identity for for who they
want to be um and so i think it actually
helped so you initially started
sending out these polls on all of your
different platforms your reddit and your
only fans and your twitter to try to get
as many respondents as possible but that
really snowballed into something bigger
it wasn't just you um it wasn't just an
exercise in brand differentiation for
you where guys ended up being into it
but it's also like a thing that you are
known for uh and you've sort of
established a reputation for yourself as
this uh data scientist
tell me more about how that evolved i've
been sort of dabbling in it for a very
long time i think i did my first survey
in like 2014. and in hindsight it was
really terrible i was just like let's
ask people questions and then i didn't
understand about like question structure
or how to process data afterwards or
anything um i'm not formally educated i
was homeschooled and did not really go
to college uh so all this has been
self-taught or through like tutors or
friends who've helped me uh so my
knowledge is pretty spotty and i'm
learning all the time uh i'm like pretty
good in some areas and like really
underdeveloped in others so we met at
hereticon this conference in miami which
is sort of a gathering for
oddball intellectuals and you were on
stage and you made the really
interesting comment i don't really get
that mad when i'm sexually assaulted the
interviewer who shall remain nameless
sort of got really uncomfortable and let
out like an awkward chuckle and then
moved on very quickly which i thought
was a sort of odd response because i was
like wait that's you know a very
heretical thing in our society
especially in the current moment and i
think that's so interesting like i want
nothing more than to understand what you
mean by that so why don't you get that
mad when you're sexually assaulted
that's a great question now's your
opportunity to expand on it i'm not sure
it's probably a couple different reasons
like one is i suspect that i just uh
am like not very sensitive to negative
stimuli like if you do like a bad thing
to me i'm like ah okay and i move on
with my life and so there's some sort of
like predisposition maybe genetic there
that just it it rolls off me pretty well
typically when i've been sexually
assaulted it hasn't resulted in like
meaningful damage to me like i'm not
doesn't break a leg and i don't get
pregnant or anything and it's like
annoying i don't like it um but
it doesn't feel like it really sticks in
me very much it's like well if nothing
bad happened then i can just move on
with my life
um and it also depends on the context a
lot like i've been sexually assaulted
while working as an escort before
and that was like pretty unpleasant but
but also it's like
uh it feels kind of an extension of what
i'm doing already a little bit uh that i
feel like people are going to if they
hear that they're going to misinterpret
that
what do you mean by that though i think
that's really interesting does it feel
sort of like to some degree you're
suspending a sense of what you want to
do in order to engage in this voluntary
relationship this transaction and so
you know this being assaulted or having
that be violated further is a natural
extension of that yeah something like
that and to be clear i do not view
escorting as in itself sexual assault
whatsoever but it's something like maybe
you're suspending sometimes your own
needs and desires i imagine in order to
do something that you've contractually
agreed to like say you're hired to load
a bunch of boxes into a truck and you're
like loading boxes and it's like you're
consenting to it it's not like you're
the most fun thing ever but whatever
that's life and then like somebody comes
along as you're lifting something and
like dumps a whole bunch more weight on
the thing that you're lifting and it's
like you're still like in the context
where you're doing the thing and then
the situation sort of changes to become
more unpleasant um and in that case like
sure it's not great you didn't consent
to it like that shouldn't have happened
but maybe it's like a little bit easier
to handle because it's a slight
modification of what you're doing
already but it almost seems like what
you're reacting to is a sense that a
trauma or an event that is disturbing or
that you dislike doesn't have to be
something that wields so much power over
you for years and years to come which i
think runs very contrary to the cultural
moment that we're in
yeah this seems absolutely true i think
like the majority of trauma is like
culturally determined i'm not saying
that we should say things that are good
to make people who suffer them have a
good time but i am saying that like a
lot of the actual sensation of oh [ __ ]
i'm traumatized by this event comes from
the sense that this should not have
happened and that is something that
society tells you like i was uh pretty
abused when i was growing up um by my my
dad and when i got to be an adult
everybody was like oh my god i'm so
sorry they reacted with like such
sympathy and care and and stuff and that
caused me to view my childhood as very
bad because before it had just been like
oh this is kind of painful like this
sucks but like everybody has to do
things they don't like in childhood
right uh and then it was only once i got
to adulthood that culture reframed this
for me and it was in that reframing that
i experienced trauma from it and in
order to undo that trauma in myself i
had to undo that framing
and so i think that the same goes with
sexual assault and consent right like
like the the trauma of the consent a lot
of it i mean not all of it to be clear
there are like concrete bad things that
are not determined by society but a lot
of that trauma is coming from culture
telling us like oh you should be pretty
upset about that thing and then our
brains are like okay yeah you're right
you've been conducting a rape survey
online sort of in your role as this this
data scientist and public intellectual i
took it because i thought it was
fascinating and so it was some like 50
questions and basically a sliding scale
a continuum where you rank the degree to
which sort of counts as rape versus
dozen so what were your findings
yeah i had about 5500 people take the
survey um and
found a wide spectrum of things i guess
uh some some like easily packaged things
are like women tended to be more likely
to rate things as rape than men by what
degree by what factor
women's average rating was 54 out of 100
and men's was 44. i think mine was
probably around the guy response level
like maybe in the 40s so what types of
things were you surprised that people
considered to be rapey versus what types
of things were you surprised that people
broadly found to be less violating of
consent i included two controls or what
i thought were controls one was like
okay a question is very clearly rape
like somebody jumps out of a bushes
stranger they scream and stuff and the
other one was like you have sex in a
relationship to make your partner happy
i was like that's clearly not right
there's clearly a zero like nobody like
everybody has sex in their relationship
to make a partner happy uh and it was
rated pretty low but it wasn't zero it
got rated 13. there was in fact another
one that got rated even lower than that
which was with having sex with an
unenthusiastic sex worker
which i thought people are going to rate
higher than that that was very
surprising to me what types of things
were universally declared rape by people
jumping out of bushes and screaming and
fighting removing a condom without
consent stealthing high up there
stealthing yeah or like a husband
forcing cyclone his wife even if the
wife thinks this is okay comes from a
culture where this is okay
interesting i feel like that's maybe a
response that like would be affected by
whether people are us-based or
international
because i wonder whether in some
cultures where like marital rape laws
have been either are still in place or
were more recently repealed whether
people have slightly different cultural
attitudes toward that yeah i also
suspect um so
i suspect that there's like this is one
spectrum along which people evaluate if
something is rape or not like to what
degree does like the the person thinking
that it's normal make it okay like if
both people involved are like this is a
normal thing to do like does it still
count as rape and this is like one thing
that seemed to divide people you asked a
lot of questions if i recall about
people who are neurodivergent or
otherwise like or disabled uh and the
degree to which they're sort of capable
of consenting to sex what did you find
about that like it seemed to be like
roughly in the middle people had
different views on it but one thing
about this that i find interesting like
one reason why like mental capacity
seems
really fascinating to me is because we
have a lot of opinions about uh like
teenagers you know or children like
their ability to consent to sex and
generally the the perception is no they
can't but maybe like a 16 year old could
have sex with another 16 year old and
this is fine but like the reason why we
say children cannot conject consent to
sex is because they don't have the
mental capacity to agree so i'm like
okay what if we take a mentally disabled
person who has the mental capacity of a
16 year old for their entire life right
and so do our intuitions stay the same
there like should we never allow them to
have sex with anyone um and so that's a
really good way of like testing our
intuitions about this and what do
people's intuition say about that i did
had a teen having sex with adult
questions okay um in in in the question
of this was like at least visibly eager
like the 16 year old expressed being
very excited about this thing and then i
also asked a question about somebody
with with down syndrome uh very eagerly
having wanting to have sex with somebody
who is neurotypical and it was not
considered rape very very very low for
the down syndrome person but it was was
considered pretty rapey for the 16 year
old that's fascinating that's so
different than how i would anticipate
those responses to go what other big
gender differences did you see other
than the sort of
top line men tended to rate things as
less rapey than women did on average
what other gender differences did you
see were there any themes that came up
where men generally regarded something
as permissible whereas women didn't
relationship pressure was a big one so
so scenarios that involve some level of
like uh emotional desire for sex or
asking for sex when the woman doesn't
want to typically in this context of a
relationship men were very much like
that's not rape and women were like that
is definitely more rapey which was
pretty surprising to me at hereticon you
talked about how you don't
you're not generally in favor of
government intrusion into sex and into
people's sex lives but you did mention
that you would sooner have if you had to
you would sooner have the government
regulate only fans than regulate
in-person sex work
why is that if we're going by the like
how much harm does this cause the
population sort of thing my my guess my
intuition is that only fans like might
be more damaging to society as a whole
than escorting and to be clear both of
them are not very damaging i think it's
worth it we're not really in favor of
state intrusion into people's sex life
generally as a principal in this room
yeah um but but only fan seems seems
worse to me um
mostly in the sense that it feels uh
much more impersonal and asymmetrical it
feels more like a system of sex as
opposed to like genuine sexual
interaction like with escorting there's
a very human thing it feels very organic
and i feel like a little bit like a
hippie talking about this i'm not
typically very hippie like except for
all the lsd but uh it it really does
feel different um like i when i went
from camming to escorting to only fans
the escorting felt the healthiest to me
like i felt the best after doing it i
felt like i was doing the most good in
the world whereas the other two are very
asymmetrical it's me versus like a whole
bunch of guys i'm fascinated by this
because i think it's um counter how a
lot of people maybe not libertarians and
people who are pro-sex work but the idea
that escorting is doing good in the
world runs counter to how a lot of
people view it but you you're saying you
felt that really viscerally what did
that feel like to you how would you
describe that feeling to somebody who's
perhaps opposed to it it feels much more
dehumanizing to be on only fans and
again happy only fans exist this is not
a criticism like but it did feel like i
was actually dehumanizing the men more
and they were dehumanizing me because
it's about numbers we have 50 churn
we're like i'm thinking about funnels
i'm thinking about like how many i's
what's the conversion rate i'm thinking
about like at what time of day do i post
this thing to get the most unlocks
that sort of thing and so the men are no
longer like individual men right they're
they're like little data points in a
thing that i'm trying to maximize i'm no
longer interacting with a human i'm
interacting with like like a massive
ants on the ground that i'm trying to
like corral into giving me their money
and it's like that terrible movie the
social network where vincent cartizer
has all the computer monitors and is
like pulling all the levers and it's
that's how you're looking at only fans
as opposed to escorting yeah exactly and
so it's fun like i owe my fans it's like
fun in that kind of way but it
definitely is removing some sort of
human element from the sexual
interaction anyway that's like
impossible to do with escorting like
with escorting you're just placed in
front of a human being and you like make
eye contact and you talk with each other
and get to know each other and then you
just that is just powerful in a way that
like i can't replicate anywhere else you
said there's a component of almost
therapy you're doing and selling men to
some degree an image of themselves uh
what was that like more specifically in
escorting like do you have examples of
that of like these deeper sort of
connections that you made there were
definitely several men that i knew that
like i still think about really fondly
to this day um
there's like
like there's guys who i think there were
two dying of cancer and were like i
don't want to die without having the
warm embrace of a woman in my life i was
like sure that's i'm like fully for here
for you to help with that or there was
one guy who was like really depressed
and
our first session like we sat down on
the bed and we were talking and it just
felt to me like there was like sadness
behind him
and then i just asked about that and
then one thing led to another and the
entire session was just like me holding
him as he sobbed into me
um and that was it we didn't have sex
um i've had sex with a quadriplegic who
was like literally in in a chair who
couldn't move
um i was like yeah that feels good like
i'm helping you get something that just
you can't get anymore it feels really
human and caring to me you've talked a
little bit about what percentage of your
clients are married and how it's
actually a pretty high number
how do you think about that in this
phenomenon of married men seeking you
out in my survey about 50 of men who
seek out escorts are married and this
seems to hold true with my personal
experience
um and often they would talk very fondly
about their wives be like my wife is
great like i never want to hurt her and
it felt very compartmentalized a lot of
times men to go to go to escort
specifically because of that
compartmentalization right they don't
want to like have an affair with
somebody at work who might like bleed
into their life and actually like pull
out more of their emotional resources
they want a like a just a sex experience
that they can like put on the shelf and
go away because often they care about
their wife and they want to protect
their wife from from any sort of like
bleed over they're like oh the thing
that i'm not getting is sex i'm just
gonna go have that and
and that's it usually it's men like
older men whose wives just are not
sexually interested anymore like have a
very low sex drive maybe are too
exhausted they're just it's just not for
them and the guy doesn't want to
pressure her to like make her have sex
with him and she usually is very
uncomfortable if he would have sex with
anybody else or opening the relationship
so what he can he do to get his needs
met and a lot of people are like well
you signed up for this you know you
committed to a life with this woman but
really i think uh culture does not
adequately prepare people for this
they're just like oh you're going to be
in love forever and it's going to be
fine but it's not and these people are
blindsided by it and so in order to cope
with this they often go and see an
escort and this can help them preserve a
marriage that may have fallen apart if
they if they didn't do something like
this
one thing that we've been paying a lot
of attention to
at reason is the backlash toward sex
work and toward porn and this sort of
push toward regulating a lot of these
sites like only fans and cracking down
on payment processing capabilities of
these sites there's also been this
really interesting uh sort of social
conservative trad movement that's been
bubbling up in the last few years that i
imagine you have a lot of exposure to by
being a very visible sex worker online
what are these objections like and how
have you addressed them in the past or
how do you look at addressing their
objections
yeah the objections are typically
something like this is damaging society
in some way or it's like an addiction uh
that is like hurting your psyche um it's
like damaging your ability to bond to a
parabon to have intimacy to love
uh
and
these don't feel true based on my
personal experience it's possible that
they are true for some people like i
don't want to just outright be like all
of your criticisms are incorrect but
there's also a thing which i feel that
they miss which is like the trade-offs
right like we have a lot of trade-offs
from driving cars we get into accidents
and die there's pollution and i'm not
going to say that no nobody dies from
driving cars but i'm also not going to
be like we should get rid of cars
like for any sort of like new thing that
we have instituted
there's going to be benefits to it and
there's going to be cons and the
question is not are there cons the
question is are are the benefits worth
it and so i feel like a lot of the
criticisms i get are missing that
they're like oh well there's cons
we should stop the cons and i'm like
okay yes there's there's cause uh but
i'm not sure that like
doing something that ruins the benefits
is like worth it like a lot of people
watch porn for a reason porn has been
super beneficial to me in my life
personally and i'm like i would be like
pretty pissed people got rid of it how
so how has it been beneficial to you
it's made me feel like less [ __ ] up or
something like i have like odd sexual
desires uh and i study kinks right so
like i talk to so many people who have
odd sexual desires and the existence of
porn sort of like validates this in a
way can be like oh i'm not like weirded
abnormal there are other people like me
out there producing content for each
other to make each other like happy and
satisfied
and that seems really wonderful are you
more worried about the social threat
from this sort of like quickly
this this trad movement that's quickly
gaining traction or are you more worried
about the threat from politicians uh
people like josh hawley who tend to
really ride the wave of porn panic and
and attempt to oftentimes spread lies
and misinformation about sex trafficking
and stuff like that are you more worried
about the cultural threat or the
governmental threat or do you see them
as two sides of the same coin they work
in tandem right like governments make
laws based off of cultural pressure
often but if i had to compare them i
would say i'm more afraid of the people
that hold the power and so this sounds
like the politicians i'm okay with
cultural movements as long as they don't
use force in them like i'm okay with
people genuinely arguing hey i think
this is harmful for you like i'm down to
have this discussion i'm down for you to
make like a strong movement that sweeps
the land but i am not okay with you
making laws that prevent me from doing
what i feel is good for me like that is
the border here this is what like the
respect of freedom is so i'm fine with
the culture but like the thing is i just
at this point don't trust the culture to
be able to still respect freedoms of
people they disagree with do you see a
tension between the fact that so much of
the tech crowd is kind of a huge fan of
yours and
seems generally interested in in some of
these pro-sex work ideas but then
there's also this interesting almost
trad wave that's sweeping a lot of that
to me i sort of sometimes see the same
people
celebrating some things but almost
heralding the the sort of impending
cultural crackdown yeah i'm glad that i
exist for this or something like like
i've had a couple people tell me that i
changed their perception of sex workers
like oh i didn't know sex workers could
be smart like i've heard that phrase a
couple times from different people
um and so i think there's some sort of
like humanizing that i'm doing and i'm
bringing to it and and like maybe that
this is sort of like helping provide
some balance to the the wave of trad
coming through um i bet i don't know the
best the best i can do is just be honest
and wait what's an assumption people
make about your work or your career
trajectory that you dislike or you wish
they wouldn't make there's a lot of
those i really don't like that people
think that i'm doing it just to be edgy
i really deeply am curious and weird and
it feels very true and organic to me and
people from the outside often see what
i'm doing and think wow she's like
deliberately trying to provoke reactions
in people
and there's not much more to it in a
world where ayla makes the rules what
types of cultural norms would you like
to see
surrounding uh how we think about sex
and or how sex is regulated or perhaps
deregulated generally i prefer like
individual autonomy over like any sort
of regulation there so if like if you
want to go sell your body on the sex
worker go
for it
um good for you
i would prefer people to be like a
little bit more flexible about how they
think about sexual trauma like be not
necessarily that you're trying to tell
people that they are not traumatized but
rather that you're more open to the idea
that maybe you don't have to be
traumatized um there's a lot more
flexibility for actually finding out the
way people genuinely feel about their
sexual experiences before trying to tell
them how they should be feeling about it
feels like a great norm to me what are
your greatest hopes and fears for
the future of sex either the future of
sex work or the future of our cultural
norms around sex i i'm pretty hopeful
about it like our trajectory so far has
been towards greater sexual permission
and like likely there's going to be up
and down waves as we get better about it
and in the short term it may in fact get
worse but i'm pretty optimistic for it
overall like sexual permission comes out
of like losing consequences for sex we
no longer get pregnant when we have sex
which is incredible uh unless we want to
throughout all of human history if you
have sex it makes a baby and pretty
scary it makes sense that we had a bunch
of like [ __ ] up rules to try and
govern that but we no longer have that
and now for the first time humanity's
like we can [ __ ] without babies and it's
leading to some really weird stuff um
and like to some like negative outcomes
too like if you just sort of release a
pressure on a population you get like a
whole bunch of things some positive some
negative and so yeah there's some like
possible really negative outcomes that
might come from this especially with
people's reaction to it like people are
not sort of like evolutionary like in a
physical sense like ready for there to
be like a whole bunch of sex happening
all the time with whoever you want you
know like the the sex utopia or
something uh which which makes sense
it's reasonable but like a lot of people
have backlash to this by like maybe
imposing like draconian laws that are
like supposedly meant to protect women
you know while simultaneously
victimizing them i'm thinking of like
joe biden's like violence against women
act and stuff like that attempts to uh
protect women who are victims of
domestic violence but ends up actually
inviting the police into all sorts of
domestic altercations in a manner that
sometimes doesn't actually help and i
think that this is an exact a great
example of a theme which is like oh
we're starting to see a negative outcome
and we try in our sort of like
incompetent but good good-intentioned
way to try to implement some sort of law
to fix it but it's just like a series of
like band-aids uh on on like a pretty
deep problem and usually i think that
problems are better left to sort of like
sort themselves out um if you if you can
do that like without like
creating any force on it and what are
ways in which you think the coming sex
utopia uh will actually be wonderful
yeah i would love people to be able to
get their needs met when they need to
like i think the institution of monogamy
is great for some reasons and pretty uh
misleading in others like like i
mentioned earlier uh people go into
monogamy without fully understanding
that they're going to have to spend a
life you know like sexually tied to just
this partner and that people change
really drastically and we have no
affordance no room for people to try to
get their needs met in that sort of
situation so i'm hoping in the future we
are much more like flexible and
understanding about this sort of thing
that we sort of decouple like uh
abnormal sexual behavior from threat uh
like oh you can do this thing that is
not like standard accepted and like bad
things are not going to happen like i
i'm i hope that we as a culture will
sort of like actually like feel that hit
us in a deep way and then move according
to that do you think that will happen
i suspect so i don't i assuming that we
don't all die in some sort of horrific
ai extinction like it might take a
couple centuries but i suspect we're
moving in that direction yeah that would
be really sad if the ai extinction
happened before the sexual utopia yes
thank you so much for talking to reason
yeah thank you
you